WHEN YOU GET TO HEAR, WHAT DO WE
KNOW THAT'S DIFFERENT HERE?
>> YOU CAN ARGUE THAT THERE IS A
LEGAL PREDICATE TO START THE
INVESTIGATION, IT DOESN'T REALLY
MATTER TO ME.
WHAT I'M HERE TO TELL YOU AND
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, IF IT
STARTED LEGITIMATE, IT BECAME
CRIMINAL PRETTY QUICK.
HERE'S WHAT I'M GOING TO SAY TO
HORWITZ.
DO YOU AGREE WITH ME THAT IN
JANUARY 2017 AFTER THE SUB
SOURCE TOLD THE FBI AND
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE EVERYTHING
IN THE DOSSIER IS A BUNCH OF
B.S., THAT'S WHEN IT BECAME THE
CRIMINAL
THEY TOLD THE COURT THAT THEY
WERE TRUTHFUL AND CREDIBLE.
AT THAT POINT IN TIME, THE
PEOPLE AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IN THE FBI, THEY TRAMPLE
ON THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS OF
CARTER PAGE AND CONTINUE THE
SURVEILLANCE, IT BECAME AS IF
J. EDGAR HOOVER CAME FROM THE
GRAVE AND TOOK OVER THE
INVESTIGATION GENERATE 2,017TH.
IT